in your 2005 book titled the
singularities near you predicted that
the singularity will happen in 2045. so
now 18 years later do you still estimate
that the singularity will happen
on 2045 and maybe first what is the
singularity the technological
singularity and when will it happen
Singularity is what computers really
change our view of what's important
and change Who We Are
but we're getting close to some Salient
things that will change
Who We Are
a key thing is 2029
when computers will pass the Turing test
and there's also some controversy
whether the Turing test is valid I
believe it is
most people do believe that but there's
some controversy about that but
Stanford got very alarmed at my
prediction about 2029 I made this in
1999.
in my book the age of spiritual machines
right and then you repeated the
prediction in 2005 2005. yeah so they
held the International Conference you
might have been aware of it of AI
experts in 1999 to assess this View
so people gave different predictions and
they took a poll it was really the first
time that AI experts worldwide were
pulled on this prediction uh and the
average poll was a hundred years
uh 20 believed it would never happen
and that was the view in 1999
80 believed it would happen
but not within their lifetimes
there's been so many advances in AI
uh that the poll of AI experts has come
down over the years so a year ago
something called meticulous which you
may be aware of assesses different types
of experts on the future
they again assessed what AI experts then
felt and they were saying 2042
for the joint test
for the Turing test
that says coming down and I was still
saying 2029 yeah a few weeks ago that
again did another poll and it was 20 30.
so
ax was now basically agree with me
I haven't changed at all I've dated with
2029
um and the experts now agree with me but
they didn't agree at first
so Alan Turing formulated the trying
test and right now what he said was very
little about it I mean the 1950 paper
where he had articulated the training
test
he is like a few lines that uh
uh talk about the Turing test
um and it really wasn't
very clear how to administer it
and and he said if if they did it in
like 15 minutes
that would be sufficient which I don't
really think is is the case
these large language models now some
people are convinced by it already I
mean you can talk to it and have a
conversation with you and you can
actually talk to it for hours
um so it requires a little more depth
there's some problems with large
language models which we can talk about
um
but
some people are convinced by the Turing
test now if somebody passes the Turing
test
what what are the implications of that
does that mean that they're sentient
that they're conscious or not it's not
necessarily clear what the implications
are
anyway I believe
2029 that's six seven years from now
uh we'll have something that passes the
towing tests and a valid sewing test
meaning it goes for hours not just a few
minutes can you speak to that a little
bit what is your
formulation of the touring test you
you've proposed a very difficult version
of the Turing test so what does that
look like basically it's just to assess
it over several hours
um and also have a human judge that's
fairly sophisticated on what computers
can do and can't do
um if you take somebody who's not that
sophisticated
or even a a average engineer
they may not really assess various
aspects of it so you really want the
human to challenge the system exactly
exactly on its ability to do things like
Common Sense reasoning perhaps that's
actually a key problem with the large
language models they don't do uh these
kinds of
uh tests that would involve
assessing uh chains of reasoning
um
but you can lose track of them if you if
you talk to them they actually can talk
to you pretty well and you can be
convinced by it but it's somebody that
would really convince you that it's a
human
uh whatever that takes maybe it would
take days or weeks
but it would really convince you that
it's human
um large language models
uh can appear that way you can read
conversations and they appear pretty
good there are some problems with it it
doesn't do math very well
you can ask how many legs did 10
elephants have and they'll tell you well
okay each elephant has four legs and ten
elephants so it's 40 legs and you go
okay that's pretty good
how many legs do 11 elephants have and
they don't seem to understand the
question do all humans understand that
question no that's the key thing I mean
how advanced the human do you want it to
be
but we do we do expect a human to be
able to do multi-chain reasoning
to be able to take a few facts and put
them together
not perfectly and we see we see that you
know in a lot of polls that people don't
do that perfectly at all but
um
so it's not it's not very well defined
but it's something where it really would
convince you that it's a human is your
intuition that large language models
will not be
solely the kind of system that passes
the touring test in 2029
do we need something else no I think it
will be a large language model but they
have to go beyond what they're doing now
uh I think we're getting there
and another key issue is if somebody
actually passes deterring test validly I
would believe they're conscious now not
everybody would say that it's okay we
can pass a Turing test but we don't
really believe that it's conscious
that's a whole other issue
um but if it really passes the training
test I would believe that it's conscious
but I don't believe that of uh large
language models today if it appears to
be conscious
that's as good as being conscious at
least for you in some in some sense I
mean Consciousness is not something
that's scientific
uh I mean I believe you're conscious
but it's really just a belief when we
believe that about other humans that
that at least appear to be conscious
um when you go outside of shared human
assumption
uh like our animals conscious
some people believe they're not
conscious some people believe they are
conscious
and would a machine that acts just like
a human
be conscious I mean I believe it would
be
but but that's really a philosophical
belief it's not you can't prove it I
can't take an entity and prove that it's
conscious there's nothing that you can
do there would be they would indicate
that
it's like saying a piece of art is
beautiful you can say it
multiple people can experience a piece
of art is beautiful
but you can't prove it
but it's also extremely important issue
yes I mean imagine if you had something
with nobody's conscious
the the world may as well not exist
um
and
so some people like to say Marvin rinsky
um
said well Consciousness is not
logical it's not scientific and
therefore we should dismiss it and any
any talk about Consciousness is just not
to be believed
but when he actually engaged with
somebody who was conscious he actually
acted as if they were conscious
he didn't ignore that he acted as if
Consciousness does matter exactly
whereas he said it didn't matter
well that's Myron Minsky yeah he's full
of contradictions but that's true of of
a lot of people as well
um but do you Consciousness matters but
to me it's very important
but but I would say it's not a
scientific issue
uh it's a philosophical issue and people
have different views and some people
believe that anything that makes a
decision is conscious so your light
switch is conscious its level of
conscience is low not very interesting
but but that's the consciousness
uh and anything so a computer that makes
a more interesting decision fill out
human levels but it's also conscious and
at a higher level than your light switch
uh so that's one View
uh there's many different views of what
Consciousness is so if a system passes
the touring test
it's not scientific
but uh in issues of philosophy things
like ethics start to enter the picture
do you think there would be
we would start contending as a human
species
about the ethics of turning off such a
machine
yeah I mean that's definitely come up
hasn't come up in reality yet but yet
but I'm talking about 2029 it's not that
many years from now
um so what are our obligations to it
uh it has a different I mean a computer
that's conscious it has a little bit
different uh
connotations than a human
uh we have a continuous consciousness
we're in an entity that does not last
forever
um
now actually a significant portion of
humans still exist
and are therefore still conscious
um
but anybody who is over a certain age
doesn't exist anymore
that wouldn't be true of a computer
program
you could completely turn it off and the
copy of it could be stored and you could
recreate it
and so it has a different type of
validity
uh you can actually take it back in time
you could eliminate its memory and have
it go over again I mean it has a
different kind of
connotation than humans do well perhaps
you can do the same thing with humans
it's just that we don't know how to do
that yet yeah it's possible that we
figure out all of these things on the
machine first
but that doesn't mean the machine is
unconscious
I mean if you look at the way people
react say three CPO or other uh machines
that are conscious in movies
uh they don't actually present how it's
conscious but we see that they are a
machine and people will believe that
they are conscious
and they'll actually worry about it if
they get into trouble and so on
so 2029 is going to be the first year
when a a major thing happens right and
that that will shake our civilization to
start to consider
the role of AI yes or no I mean it's
this one guy at Google claimed that the
machine was conscious
but that's just one person right so it
starts to happen at scale
well that's exactly right because most
people have not taken that position I
don't take that position I mean I've
used
uh
different things
um
uh like this and they don't appear to to
me to be conscious
as we eliminate various problems of
these large language models
uh more and more people will accept that
they're conscious
so when we get to 2029 more I think a
large fraction of people will believe
that they're conscious
uh so it's not going to happen all at
once
uh I believe that would actually happen
gradually and it's already started to
happen